I was like have you done any deals like
that I would have heard of and he's like
you know Disneyland I was like yeah he's
like a lot of Windows in Disneyland we
do all the windows in Disneyland
oh my God they bought a window company
got him a Disney contract we do all the
windows at Disney
[Music]
all right what's up we are talking about
something pretty special this episode
this is gonna be different than our
normal episodes which are you know
freewheeling freestyling today we got a
plan and the plan is we're going to talk
about companies that crush it with only
one or two employees so the reason we
thought about this was there was some
news I don't know a couple weeks ago
that a company that I had never heard of
called War graphs sold for 54 million
dollars and the yeah that's I mean
that's obviously impressive but the most
impressive part was that Warcraft was
just one dude so one guy sold his
company for 54 million dollars and uh I
don't know do you know what wargrass did
are you familiar with it is it a gaming
thing it's a gaming thing yeah so he
built basically a companion app I think
for a League of Legends so if you play
League of Legends this was like a thing
that would keep track of your stats and
stuff like that help you get better at
the game so he built this little
companion app and uh it had gotten
really popular I think he got into like
a million uh players that used it and
was generating serious revenue and so he
sold it for 51 54 million in cash and he
was upfront he was like I got half of
the uh sorry I got half of the 54
million in cash up front and I have the
other half as like my earn out that I
have to look at like you know if it hits
you know our Milestones along the way
which is just super impressive for a
one-person company and how old is the
person uh I think he started when he was
young but now it's been like you know
seven or eight years so that's amazing
I'm gonna guess some something like 30
but
the the it got me thinking it was like
everybody talks about big businesses for
good reason big businesses are awesome
uh there they are but what about Mighty
businesses what about the the guys who
are punching above their weight so
somebody who has just themselves or just
one or two people that does millions in
Revenue profitably flies under the radar
and like how many other War graphs are
there out there so
we did some research and we found some
and so that's what this episode is going
to be about and we've kind of touched on
this before we've done some of our most
popular episodes if you go on YouTube
you'll see the episode with Peter levels
I think has
a couple hundred thousand
um listens the lesson uh sorry the uh
episode about Amit Agarwal the guy who
builds uh G Suite you know maybe
basically Google Sheets plugins
um he does millions of dollars in
Revenue as just kind of one guy who was
a blogger turned app builder and so
those were some of our most popular
episodes so I think this is going to be
a good one too Sam anything else before
we jump in yeah I want to give an
honorable mention to this one person
Have you listened to juvenile growing up
remember rapper the rapper juvenile of
course you're giving him a shout out
like he's listening yeah I like last
year NPR they do this thing called the
tiny desk concert series you know what
that is it's like they're in the office
like playing acoustic songs yeah those
are cool they said who should we have
and this one guy goes you should have
Juvenile and juvenile replies and he
goes what the what that he goes WTF what
what the f is a tiny desk and hell no
and
you know what they got him to do it
anyway it happened this weekend and so
in preparation for this one-man band
show I've been listening to that
juvenile concert at the tiny desk NPR
series it was awesome it was awesome he
he remember back that ass up
it was so good it was so good I had to
be inspired him and Manny fresh in it
and it was awesome it was awesome
awesome awesome so honorable
these are the tiny Desk Awards then
let's call it that these are the tiny
Desk Awards which are the the businesses
that can be run off of one tiny desk
because it's just one or two people all
right and uh we're gonna do this like an
awards show so we have a long list but
that'd be kind of boring so we're we're
broken up into categories and we each
have our answer for the category so for
example first category
is going to be biggest one-person
business but we also have to set some
rules here yes some of these things one
person it's a bit uh vague yeah one
person oftentimes can mean like the
founder and like a team of contractors
or in many cases it's going to be
um uh agencies that they work with of
course or it started as one person and
it was that way for a long time and then
they hired a team
uh exactly so it's more of the spirit of
the law than the letter of the law here
so you know
they don't have
t-shirts for the company because you
know there's they don't have like you
know a bunch of employees and and uh you
know morale they they probably won't
have a uh an office where a bunch of
people go into it's either one or two
people who are kind of the core drivers
and maybe they use some contractors or
vendors or agencies for for other things
but uh that's that's generally the the
way we're looking at this yeah and so uh
let's get into it so what's the first
one the uh is it the the biggest so you
go first so I'm gonna do one another
gaming one that I doubt you know of
do you know what stardew valley is no
what is that so stardew Valley is this
game and if you look at the game the
game art looks like it's like 8-bit art
almost it looks like a very very
simplistic game
and it was made by one guy this guy Eric
Barone
and he's basically is like you know I'm
he gets out of school he doesn't want to
get a job so he's like well
you know I'm gonna teach myself how to
code uh instead of going to get a good
job so he's like why don't I learn how
to build a game in order to teach myself
how to code like I don't want to just
code for coding's sake I'll try to do
something with it and he always liked
these games back if you have a harvest
moon it's like this kind of like Farming
Simulator game
um there's like very simple kind of like
uh
you know it had like a cult following
and so he's like I'm gonna make my
version of Harvest Moon which was like
kind of was popular when I was a kid
like you know 15 years ago 20 years ago
and um so he spends basically uh four
years in solitude just building this
game by himself before he releases it
and for four years his job did he have a
job he just lived off his girlfriend his
girlfriend had a like a grad degree
stipend and uh and then he had a
part-time job as an usher
is amazing I mean and Usher is a
terrible unless you're literally trying
to be like a cover artist covering the
artist Usher like you know you never
want to be a notcher that's not the
that's not your crew's not going the
right direction when you're doing that
um so anyways the he launches this thing
stardew Valley has sold 20 million
copies
um it sells for 13 a pop and so uh you
know he sold this thing I think over
time it has done 150 million in sales or
Revenue
um and he's the only guy who built it
just by himself it's just honestly not
that uncommon Minecraft was largely
built the same way there's this guy
Notch who's the developer behind
Minecraft and if you've ever seen it
he'll get on Twitch and he'll just code
Minecraft like he'll just stream himself
for like 12 hours just building the game
and like I think Minecraft have more
people overall but like one guy was
really the driving force and the driving
energy around it for many many years uh
but stardew Valley is my pick for for
biggest 100 50 million off of one one
Game Dev the guy Notch when he's sold I
think he sold for like multiple billions
right three billion two billion
something like that and he uh I think he
bought like an like he outbid Beyonce
for like an 80 million dollar mansion in
uh LA and he was tweeting out or sharing
how everyone hates him now he was like
I'm so lonely this sucks but he's still
in this like fancy 80 million dollar
mansion do you remember that whole like
ordeal where he was talking about how he
like didn't give Equity to people and so
some of the people who he hired uh hated
him and he was lonely but he was having
all these huge parties and he was lost
and all that stuff do you remember all
that no I I missed all that dude he like
went through this whole Spiel on on
Twitter about how like he hates his life
but oh wow you know everything what else
is uh I'm looking at this house this
house is insane with the 80 million 70
million
it was like a it was a fat I remember
like I would love to just see Beyonce
getting the news it's like oh who who
did it who outbid me was it was it
Spielberg who was it oh no it must have
been uh but Lenny Kravitz
on this like not
ch
[Laughter]
um all right mine is a stream yard so
stream yard I'll have to uh remember
when they launched but I think they
launched in 2019 right before the
pandemic hit and it was basically a it
was a way to stream events online and
stream interviews and things like that
online these two guys scaled it to 30
million dollars in Revenue in one year
or 18 months or so and this mostly
happened because the pandemic they ended
up selling it to happen for 250 million
dollars it was a mix of cash in stock
and hop in ended up laying up off a
bunch of people uh like last year but
I've heard rumors that it's killing it
have you heard these rumors pop it yeah
no no I have not heard I've heard the
opposite of those rumors but I don't
know what have you heard well just like
when the layoffs happened and it was
like basically post covered events came
back online like in person so that's
naturally going to hurt the business
then they had massive layoffs and I
heard that the the founders had taken a
ton of secondary or something like that
so I heard like a hundred million plus
in secondary yeah but maybe the business
went well I have no idea I just heard
kind of like that generally though when
you hear those three things it's like
massive layoffs you know Market uh you
know the the crazy event that was
driving your growth has stopped and the
founders people start talking about how
much secondary the founders took it's
usually because the business is going in
the wrong direction you usually people
don't about secondaries when the
thing is exploding I don't know I I
heard the other way I I also thought
that and I heard the other way around we
talked about stream yard like right when
they were getting going and then we
talked about them again when they were
acquired did you say you knew these guys
I think I met because back when I was
doing video streaming I met like kind of
everyone in this space I I don't know I
gotta look up who these guys are but I
do know that they got to 14 million in
RR when it was just the two of them and
then it got to 30 million when they had
by that time they had hired up a team so
this is kind of like a hybrid they got
they got really far with just a couple
people and then they hired up
um you know from from as they scaled it
before they sold and I remember going to
their website when it was just them and
I there was like the founder and he was
he was on the he was on the home page
and he was giving like a tutorial video
on how to use the product it was just
him like with this camera on his lap
practically and he looked exhausted he
looked so worn out I remember this
during the pandemic when we were
thinking about using them for something
and he looked like super Haggard but it
was very impressive that these two guys
have built this to sell for 250 million
dollars and although it was cash and
stock so I don't know if the stock is
worth anything I heard it might be so
that might be one of the biggest ones
that I've heard of at least recent big
ones another big one that uh it happened
a long time ago so I have no connection
it was Plenty of Fish how much did
plenty of fish get acquired for like 550
million dollars yes hundreds yeah and uh
that was started by one guy named Marcus
who now I see online and he seems like
he like lives the most lavish life and
just does crazy and so plenty of
fish was basically one of the early
dating websites it was a Marketplace it
was like okay Cupid but I think it was
predominantly Canadian and that had to
be probably the biggest exit that I've
ever heard of for a really small small
team yeah plenty of fish was
unbelievable that guy isn't he like a
nut that Plenty of Fish founder I feel
like that's a whole another story we
should do one day I think it's a whole
another I think I don't know I haven't
researched it enough to actually like
verify the claims but I've heard like a
little like grumblings like a little
little stories that something weird is
going on but I don't know the truth
also I love the fact that you've met the
stream yard guys and they looked Haggard
and you're like it's like in Silicon
Valley when you see somebody like that
you put your arm around them and you're
like hey you all right is it is it
because of too much traction or not
enough I just need to know how I'm gonna
be super much yeah oh it's too much
traction okay okay come here come here
you sleep on my couch let me feed you
just take this check put me on your cap
table uh you know like there's really
you know one out of ten of the Haggard
people they're getting beat down by too
much demand and nine out of 10. like
that who have you met like that who else
have you met where are you I remember
you're talking to a guy who um this guy
Abner met a guy abder
and he was doing something pretty I met
him after the fact but he told me the
story and I it was it was stuck with me
and I always remember here after hearing
the story I was like I should look for
that so what happened was Twitter
started taking off in popularity uh
right when it kind of got going in
Silicon Valley like it became like a
thing
and Abner was him and his team or
they're like kind of like data science
type people
and so they were like all right what can
we build uh that makes Twitter work
better because Twitter was such a
simplistic product and at the time it
was like almost like a protocol like
anyone could kind of build apps on top
of it or use the data for something so
he's trying to build something he
doesn't know what he's doing he's like
he's sitting on a train and he starts
coding this thing he's like oh I've done
this research on sentiment analysis and
he's like I was like okay so yeah well
the story sounds a little bit boring who
cares about sentiment analysis he's like
yeah you could he's like you could
figure out like how people are feeling
about a certain topic because they're
talking about it in a certain way so he
said so tell him his story was boring
right when he got oh my you know my
channel started to drift yeah I was like
is there anyone else in this a car I
could talk to I was in a car with him in
Ethiopia you know for four hours
straight there's nowhere to run so I'm
I'm hearing I'm like all right let me
hear about the story sentimentality yeah
go ahead tell me more about your PhD and
sentiment analysis what did this do and
he's like so I was on a train and I'm
building this thing I'm trying to
analyze what people are saying on
Twitter to see if I could get the
sentiment the current mood or whatever
he's like but then I realized
actually what I'll do is instead of
figuring out their mood I'll just figure
out what are they talking about a lot of
like a lot more than usual that's kind
of interesting and he basically created
trending for Twitter off of Twitter oh
cool so he's like he's like oh I could
figure out that the word Olympics
normally is only said this much but it's
being said 10 standard standard
deviations more so that means Olympics
is trending the the it's it's above its
par and he's like this is super cool
like I basically have the 10 things that
people are talking about on Twitter I
can kind of get that I get that signal
in a way that you couldn't really get at
the time on Twitter and so he creates
this and they create a separate website
off of Twitter called Twitter trending I
forgot what it was called Zone website
and they start getting millions of hits
on this thing and they're just trying to
and as and he's trying to keep it keep
it up because he's basically drinking
from the Twitter fire hose and he's got
all this traffic and so he's trying to
keep both of them working eventually
Twitter buys them so they become like
employees
10 through 20 or something of Twitter oh
sick and at the time Twitter had the
fail well it was just like constantly
Twitter the service was going down it
was had so much usage and it was like in
this Web 2.0 like it wasn't like
scalable yet they hadn't figured out how
to scale it and he told me he's like
he's like for six months he's like I
just woke up every day with like an
imprint of my keyboard on my forehead
like I had just passed out I was working
trying to keep this damn Side Up pass
out wake up
uh where was I and I just kept going
he's like that was six months straight
of my life he's like I've never
experienced anything like it
and at the time I remember thinking oh
there's levels to this thing like that's
what it feels like when you really have
one of the winners like and if you talk
to people early at Facebook and they
talk about like what the what what it
was like working early at Facebook
Facebook it's like when people talk
about living in New York they're like
just the energy was it's the energy you
can't explain it and it's like that's
how that's what you get when you're
inside one of these generational
companies at the early stage when
they're they're scaling too fast
dude that's exciting I love that one um
I like hearing those old stories like
that I always read those old books like
the hatching Twitter and all that I
love that yeah me too um all right
next let's go to let's wait let's go to
a highest degree of difficulty we'll
skip a category and come back to it okay
so this is the hardest one the hardest
example the one that we're like how the
hell did you even do that and there's no
way anyone else would have done this you
go first all right I have one it's
called tiny wow so I think the URL is
just tinywow.com so do you have that
pulled up tiny while yeah got it all
right so I met this guy he's a member of
Hampton that's why I met him his name is
Evan Gower he had a uh another website
called Tech junkie maybe you heard of
tech junkie but they like just talked
about like Tech topics whatever it's
pretty normal website but he ended up
selling it for eight figures and on the
side he started this thing called tiny
wow which is a bunch of tools that
include like how to convert a PDF but
then image editing tools that use Ai and
it's one of those websites where you
Google like convert this file to PDF it
is able to he's able to come up first
right now it has 6.6 million visits a
month and the reason it's yeah it's
insane the reason it's interesting is
right now it only does 20 000 a month in
Revenue because he says I haven't I just
haven't turned on any of the um
monetization it just has like uh little
ads he goes I'm going to turn it on
eventually but right now I'm just
enjoying the summer and time at my
family so I haven't really like dug deep
and like built it and so basically this
guy Evan he wasn't you talking about the
weather put on AdSense what are you
doing
Evan this is insane dude that's the cool
part about uh these one-person
businesses and this is another guy who
I'm gonna tell a story about has said
the same thing he goes I felt like
taking the summer off so I just let it
ride for a little while uh so this guy
Evan he basically had a history as a a
developer he says he doesn't do any
development now but he has a team of
three people who are helping him or one
contractor who helps him with uh
overseas who's helped him actually like
build and Implement he basically just
draws it and Designs it but the reason
why this thing is taken off is if you
Google or do you remember like do you
ever see those videos on Tick Tock that
say like here's five websites that
should be illegal but aren't so good
that they should be illegal yeah
so that is basically how it the the
website got popular is it's gotten
popular from those videos and so the
reason why this is really hard to create
because a getting traffic to a a like a
Content site or any type of website like
this it's very challenging oftentimes
building the product is not the hard
part it's getting users and getting 60
point six million visits a month mostly
from social quite challenging we'll see
if he's able to turn this but I asked
him I was like how big can this get he's
like well like I think of like canva so
I'm like can we I think it can make tens
of millions of dollars a year in Revenue
because we're gonna ultimately we have
this traffic we can have like a feature
that says hey you can edit this uh
picture using our platform and we'll
charge a small fee I think this actually
could be a big business but right now
it's really tiny he told me it cost ten
thousand dollars a month to run and it's
making twenty thousand dollars a month
in Revenue wow yeah do you know how much
uh
how much remove that BG makes who do you
ever use remove.bg
no what is that oh that's I mean that's
that was the old way it's like if you
need to remove a background from an
image like you need to just cut out the
object and remove the background
remove.bg was this website that was uh
like just because of traffic yeah it was
just a go-to and uh oh my God 50 to 60
million in monthly monthly visits so
it's just like insane and remove.bg it
just had a Stranglehold for me at least
on on doing this it was like super quick
you just drag your image in it just
removes the background boom there you go
and uh and then they charge for like yo
you want it like 1080P or whatever they
started charging for like little things
like remove this Watermark and
um I'm sure this thing crushes you know
I I don't know I don't know how how much
uh Revenue they do now but I'm sure this
is one of these like Mighty businesses
where it's a very small team uh
canva acquired them it says that they
had at least 100 million people coming
to their website last year yeah um
that's a CR that's crazy so it's
acquired by canva so you can probably I
don't know if canva has gone public yet
maybe they have I think actually they
just did a last month you might be able
to dig through their numbers and see if
they got Acquired and for how much but
that's crazy that's so much traffic this
site tiny while definitely could be
something like that they started this in
2019.
um it's this company collidio
um and then they so they started in 2019
they sold it this was 2021 so two years
later for roughly 100 million dollars
wow and uh wow do they have funding I
think the parent company it looks like
it's a side project of the parent
company the reason why I said these are
the hardest to make is getting that
scale of traffic that fast is so
challenging you know like there's a lot
of like software products that we're
gonna name as one person companies and
that's challenging in the sense of like
you have to put it in a ton of hours uh
and you actually have to like invent
stuff and that's very challenging but
getting traffic to me is more of an
intellectual challenge where it's like I
have no idea like where to start like
whereas with starting with software like
I I'm gonna make this one feature then
I'll do this other feature I'll talk to
my users it's a little bit involves a
little bit of luck a little bit of skill
but getting a lot of traffic to your
website early on I think there's less
people that know how to do that and so
that's why I think that this is one of
the harder things to start so here's my
my answer for highest degree of
difficulty
photo p so photo p is very very similar
basically it's one guy who recreated the
entirety of Photoshop in a web browser
for free
so oh my God Photoshop is one of the
most complicated products in the world
he recreated it by himself
gives it away for free and made it work
in the browser which Photoshop doesn't
Photoshop is a you know how you have to
download the app in order to make it
work it's just remarkable the guy barely
monetizes it uh doesn't want to sell it
and uh if you go just search his like
just search photo P Reddit
um or like you know founder Reddit he
goes and he talks about like you know
why he built it how he built it
um and what you know what how he thinks
about it or whatever it's pretty insane
and I think how much traffic does it get
uh traffic wise like 13 million
according to similar web uh per month
and um
he does at the time this was a couple
years ago he said that he was doing a
hundred thousand a month
um off this thing and it was like
literally from the most basic
absolute most basic of uh
of like ads like this is one guy Ivan
who made it and it's he's just like puts
like the very simple Banner ad on the
site and makes like 100
000 a month he uh did a post at Hacker
News on April 11 2021 he goes hey guys
I'm Ivan I'm the creator of photopee I
made almost a million dollars in the
last 12 months 90 from ads the rest is
from premium uh which is useless you pay
to hide ad so it's not even much of a
premium when you start your own project
you never know if it'll make 250 000 but
if you get hired you can be quite sure
that you will never make more than 250
000 and so that's why I started it and
so this company photo P I don't know how
big it is but depending on how many
users it has I could see this getting
sold for nine figures over a hundred
million dollars so
um he did an AMA on Reddit and they said
uh hey have you hired your first
employee yet this was a year ago and uh
he says oh after I did my first AMA on
Reddit uh lots of great people got in
touch I did end up hiring one guy from
Prague who uh who went to my university
but it'll take some time for him to get
familiar with the code he hasn't done it
it is like it hasn't done yet
it's pretty crazy how this guy uh
operates so why do you think this is the
most challenging uh just like
technically recreating Photoshop feature
for feature is absolutely insane like I
think that's just an insane Endeavor
um
and then making it work in the browser
like making it performance in a browser
is not easy either so like for one
person to do this I think it's crazy
that's insane yeah I uh the the cool
thing about these like one I think the
the downside of these one-person
companies is that everything relies on
you
and that you don't have like anyone else
to ask for help and you can't hire
anyone you can't have anyone better than
you doing something because you're the
only person
and so in order to do this I think a lot
of these people they have a they have a
handful of traits that we'll talk about
in the end but I don't understand how he
could grind that hard for that long with
all this pressure on him by the way this
guy says he put seven thousand hours
into it before he made any money from it
that's insane so I think that that just
takes so much will do you remember Viral
Nova it was a guy named Scott de long so
Viral Nova was basically an Upworthy
clone it was a it says like they're like
here's a list of 10 reasons why you
don't want to go swimming after eating
you're not going to believe number seven
and so this guy would talk about like
how it was just him writing 10 articles
a day and he was like I'm the pressure
of all this traffic and all the success
it's killing me I feel so worn out all
the time and I don't understand how some
people can sustain that for a really
long time like this photo P guy yeah
this is like you know when you go to
someone's house
and they're like oh do you want to see
my model train set I'm building you're
like what uh yeah sure why not I'm here
and they take you down to the basement
and then it's just like
they've recreated like the city of
Vienna and through their like and
they're just tinkering on this like one
thing they're like uh how many hours how
long have you been doing this and
they're like oh I just come here every
night I love it and this is what I do it
makes me feel so good and you're like
holy this is like the most intense
hobby that's how that's how I'm not that
guy I'm not that type of person are you
you're definitely not I think right come
on
if not uh yeah I envy those people
that's an amazing uh willpower all right
let's do another one let's do on the
other end easiest to recreate so which
of these one person one or two person
businesses do you think are easiest to
recreate that um is the opposite of the
highest degree of difficulty go ahead
um so mine would be anything that sells
information or service so I put just any
course creator but you and I know a
bunch of these people of which you and I
are both of those people uh you know we
make hundreds of thousands or Millions
dollars a year from like a course or two
and I think they're fairly easy to
recreate another one is uh there's a
company called design Joy you know what
they do I believe it's a design
subscription basically that's him yeah
but the way that he positions it it
seems really hard to imagine that that's
the truth but basically it's just this
designer that you pay
thousands of dollars a month for and you
ask them to make small changes to
different design related stuff and he
claims that it's just him but I I
believe he claims that yeah but he says
it sounds like he does a hundred
thousand dollars a month so he does 1.2
million a year or so around that range
and it's basically you buy a
subscription plan so you pay and you buy
like the five it's like four or five
thousand a month
um
and then you you basically get one
request at a time
um and that's it you get to just say I'd
like this design thing done and he turns
around in some I don't know what his SLA
is of how long he takes to uh to do this
but it's like it's cheaper than hiring a
full-time designer probably unless like
in the US
um
but yeah that's the I think that's the
easiest to recreate but also the worst
to run which we'll talk about later but
that's probably the easiest one it's
like a bunch do you know any other
course people that do like like I know
Sam Evans does 10 million in Revenue 5
million profit and for a while it was
just him I met these guys I met a guy
recently who does like a product
management course and I was like oh my
God who's taking a product management
course he goes no no it's how to base
your job interview as a product manager
like how to get a job as a PM at one of
these tech companies and I think he was
doing what was he doing but like 2
million a year or something like that I
think they were doing like two what two
2.5 they had 2.5 million a year uh
roughly in in Revenue I think it was
like 80 percentish margins and what they
would do is they would basically say
they would give away free content that
was like
how to you know how to get a job as a PM
how to interview as a PM how to uh prep
for this interview what it was like
talking to a Facebook PM blah blah they
give away free content to get you kind
of on the email list and get you to the
website and then they're like hey do you
want to like get a job as a PM which
will pay you let's call it 120 000 a
year if you want that job
um buy this course and join this cohort
of course or whatever and they basically
sell this course for a couple thousand
dollars that's going to help you get
this job that's going to pay you over a
hundred thousand dollars and that's like
a very simple value proposition for
somebody who wants to uh wants to do
that with their career
and it was just him it was him in three
it was it was three of them three three
PMS that kind of like got together and
made this thing another example of an
easy one to start I think I told you
about this it's called cyber lead so you
go to get cyberleads.com so it's
c-y-b-e-r leads so get cyberleads.com
it's this guy named Alex West and
basically it's a newsletter where I I
think it costs four to a thousand
dollars a month so four hundred to a
thousand dollars a month depending on
what you get what you do but basically
he goes and he hand picks different
companies that have recently raised
money and based off a bunch of
attributes he thinks are about to hire
an agency and then he gets all these
agency owners to sign up to his service
and he emails this list out once a month
along with like the contact information
the hiring decision or the hiring uh uh
like whoever's managing ad spend
whatever and you can just contact him on
he's got your face and quota as a
testimonial do you use this no I don't
use this but I talked I talked about it
on the Pod uh I talked about it on the
Pod like two years ago I've never used
it uh I've never you've never used it
but he sure used you he is he was a big
I don't know is there anything can I can
you say anything about these people who
do this I talked about it on the Pod I
said it's so freaking simple the value's
so clear I guess I said that on the
podcast and he uses that as a quote is
there anything I could do decide to take
them down you can always say that
um oh sorry let me wrap up my thing
selling information so anything that you
sell information that's the easiest
thing to start yeah I think uh so I went
the same route but I'm gonna give more
detail because I think when you tell
somebody selling information is the
easiest way they're like cool what so
what do I do so I gave three
examples yeah but I think you have to
break it down a little further so
um you know this guy Lenny Lenny Russian
last name I don't know I like Letty
Rogowski or vegetative uh something
something along those lines I like Lenny
so Lenny I think used to work at Airbnb
or something he was like a growth slash
like product guy and so he's got Lenny's
newsletter he's got Lenny's communities
he's got Lenny's job board and basically
he was like I'm gonna become he's like
I'm gonna put out tons of free thought
leader content on a specific super Niche
topic that only certain people are gonna
care about but they're gonna care a lot
and that's that's kind of the key with
this stuff is how do you put out free
content to establish yourself as an
authority in a niche so that you can
then monetize that through either
Consulting Services job board
paid Community or um or paid content
paid newsletter right that's that's the
formula and you can look at the um the
design Joy guy he does exactly this he
puts out free content examples of design
work and then says you can hire me for
design work
um Lenny does the same thing he puts out
free content he's got really good stuff
like you know how did these 10 huge
marketplaces how did they get their
first thousand users and he goes deep
and he's like I'm gonna interview them
I'm gonna talk to them I'm going to get
the real answer on the specific zero to
one question that's going to be highly
relevant to other people going through
that same challenge I think he has a
podcast too he's got a podcast like at
one point his job board was doing a
couple hundred thousand I'm sure the
newsletter does a couple hundred
thousand in sponsorships I think about
monthly or annually annually
um at least these are minimum
way more like I know at the beginning
his job boards crushing I don't know
what they're doing now but like I would
bet his entire roll-up of job board
um content sponsorship so podcast plus
newsletter and then uh he's got a paid
thing right Ben he's got like a paid
paid Community what's it what do you
think bloody's total thing is 2 million
three million
yeah for sure about two to three million
uh a year and he did that I would say in
a period of like two and a half three
years it seems like like I think he
think he has a fun too he kind of put
his foot down on the content side I like
he kind of appeared on the scene I would
say like two two-ish years ago
um obviously you had to know your stuff
right so he's like you know spent time
learning you know a decade being awesome
inside these companies in order to do so
I don't mean to make it sound overly
simplistic but there are people who did
it without that too so another example
is uh Harry dry one of my favorite
content creators in the whole world a
guy I tried to recruit like a hundred
times to do something with me because I
feel like made to do something great
um he keeps he keeps bullshitting and
not saying yes but he's gonna say yes
eventually
so he's got marketing examples he does a
great job with this blog called
marketing examples now I don't know how
much marketing examples makes I would
guess quarter million to half a million
as just him making content I think he's
young he's very young he didn't do the
put in 10 to 15 years become an industry
like like do the job cut your teeth then
go make content he's like no I'm pretty
sure I could just look at what's out
there and like give my opinion on it and
it'll work I'll study this and
that's how I feel like you know a lot of
people also can do it you can be the
Curious novice approaching these uh
topics and become an expert just by
studying them intensely and so uh I
think Harry dry would also be one of the
easiest to recreate not because he's not
talented he's super talented but I think
that's kind of something anyone can do
anybody could just say yo I'm gonna
study what makes tick tocks go viral and
I'm gonna put up content about viral
tick tocks I'm gonna become the expert
of breaking down Tick Tock going viral
and then brands are going to know me as
the guy that they should talk to you
about Tick Tock Consulting right like or
like advertising on Tick Tock and like
you could just build your Niche audience
and your Niche Authority in that space A
lot of people are trying to do this AI
right now
and the thing about Lenny and Harry was
people were doing so first of all like a
newsletters Community podcast that's
existed since forever uh so it's not a
unique business model and also people
have been talking about that type of
stuff for a long time but what's
interesting is that they were both
early-ish where there was only maybe I
don't know how many but they felt like
they were early-ish talking about it to
this customer to this community on this
platform so both of those guys I think
got popular on Twitter right before the
pandemic started I think I remember
seeing Harry in 2018 2019 which I wasn't
even really using Twitter as a power
user back then but they all seem a
little bit early so I think timing
matters for a lot of these things uh
speaking of which that Facebook threads
thing no idea if that's going to be a
thing or not but that's an example of
like hey there's this new thing right
now if you want nothing to lose you
better be there yeah just go get go be
around there see what's going on yeah
that's one of those things people did
with Clubhouse I don't know if that
worked out or not but uh the way I say
it is like you uh most most
entrepreneurs were actually surfing
waves you don't get to create the wave
but you do have to paddle out you got to
be on your board out there in the water
you got to paddle out and you know which
is a takes effort and then you gotta
wait and sometimes it's a dud sometimes
it's just a small wave you're gonna have
to paddle back out again well when you
catch a good one you know that's when
you get and we'll see how good you are
at surfing you might Wipe Out the first
couple times you try it but like that's
your job as an entrepreneur is to paddle
out be out there and start trying to
Surf these waves and get a sense for
where are the big waves and um and how
do I not wipe out when I do when I do
find one
so this episode you're giving a really
in-depth surf analogy last episode you
gave us a fat uh a pitching of baseball
what do you say a fat ass
fat pitches it was fat pitches if you
ever played bass addiction
never played baseball or serp in your
life bro I was starting right fielder
for my high school team which anybody
who knows baseball knows that means
you're the biggest scrub on the team
because that's who that's what they put
in right field is the guy who's you know
the ball never comes to right field and
yeah but did you play baseball in China
like they were just learning I might
have been in China
you went to high school and you went to
high school in China yeah I mean or or
Australia like it was hey scrubs it was
like we played the ball as it lies there
I got a golf analogy for you too uh I
was in China but that's where I'm gonna
be
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better let's go to
the next one
most fun one-person business so the one
that seems like the most fun to to work
on I'll go first
Joe Rogan so I'm pretty sure Joe Rogan's
media Enterprise
is bigger than all the late night talk
shows combined so forget the Tonight
Show Letterman and any of these whoever
the new coming in whoever these guys are
do the lettermen's been retired for 10
years Man Jimmy Fallon I don't know uh
bro who's what who's watching this stuff
his audience is bigger
he makes uh hundreds of millions and uh
he's made hundreds of millions doing it
and I'm pretty sure it's just him and
young Jamie I've heard from a few of my
friends who have been on it how it works
so basically they told me that it's
Jamie who produces it and it's Joe and
then they have one other guy named Matt
I think and I forget his name exactly I
think it was Matt and basically Matt
sends Joe a list of like 30 people
they're like hey I can get these 30
people these 30 let me know who you want
and sometimes he just ignores it every
once in a while say that person and that
person and that's all he says and I've
heard that it's just those three people
that's amazing so
I think most people just think oh Joe
Rogan he's just a podcaster yeah he is a
podcaster but that thing is a juggernaut
it is a media Juggernaut so the you know
Spotify obviously paid him you know
hundreds of millions to to be there uh
for a couple years but even before that
you know just off the sponsorships off
of uh off of the Alpha Brain you know um
product that they build off of it
Joe Rogan I think has the most fun
probably of anyone on the planet it's my
sense he took all of his Hobbies he's
like oh I like UFC he gets to be the UFC
commentator uh doing exactly what he
would want he gets to go sit ringside
commentate for these fights and analyze
the fights but he only does it for the
ones in Vegas that are an hour flight
away from him he doesn't do any of the
the ones that require a bunch of travel
um and so all the bit he does all the
best ones he does none of the worst ones
uh you know he was like I want to do
stand-up comedy so he does Stand Comedy
sells out you know uh theaters all
around the country and um you know gets
to make people laugh for a living does
this podcast where he's like I'm gonna
have conversations
with the people I want and people are
like oh Joe three hours is too long he's
like that's the type of conversation I
want to have so I'm gonna do it my way
and it worked and so like I just think
he just dictated how he wants to live
life on his terms I think he has the
most fun I think his business is
absolutely a mighty business in that
it's just let's say one two to three
people that uh is building a thing that
does you know over 100 million dollars
in Revenue which is like if you just
valued something like that you know um
traditionally which is not it's not
Apples to Apples but like
if you have a thing that can do 100
million a year in Revenue
for multiple years for multiple years
typically that's a billion dollar
property and
um you know obviously it's weird you
can't really sell legit you know Joe
Rogan Experience because you need him
it's tightly branded with him but let's
say at least he's built something worth
100 million dollars I think we can agree
on that because it's generated 100
million of profit for him and so he's
built you know with a very small team a
multi-hundred million dollar business at
the minimum and he has this new thing
called The Comedy Mothership it's like a
mile from my house in Austin and there's
always a line out the door to get into
that place yeah Comedy Club why not why
not if you drive by it at six o'clock
there's every single night there's been
a line out the door to go there and it
looks awesome right
who you got most fun
all right so scroll up to the very top
of this dock I put a link in there it
sounds like I'm trying to like promote
Hampton I'm not it's just that when I
had to prepare for this episode I just
went through our database and like
picked out people and we had just
written a blog post about this guy his
name's Joseph mambra and he started this
company called gym streak and This Guy's
super fascinating because he has all the
attributes of like what a lot of these
like Tinkers have but basically he's
from Zimbabwe moved to England when he
was like 12 or 13. that was the first
time that he experienced the internet he
taught himself how to code he taught
himself design and then he launched this
thing called gym streak at first it was
just an app for tracking your workouts
and then he what he did was he went and
got his buddy to wear one of these like
suits and that way he could do 3D
visualizations of all the exercises and
what they need to look like so he has
hundreds of them and so his app it's
free to use and they have some like
premium thing and basically you track
your workouts he uses AI to suggest
which weights you should do for the next
workout and if you don't know what the
exercise does and they'll suggest
workouts and exercises to do he has
hundreds of these 3D models of like what
a proper bicep curl or what this other
type of exercise looks like in year one
he did three hundred thousand dollars
that was in the year 2021 in year two he
did 2.5 million and his goal he says by
in the next two years I want to get the
15 to 20 million dollars a year in
revenue and he's the only employee I
don't believe he has any contractors I
think he he told me that he uh got most
of his uh users from Facebook and Tick
Tock ads and he hired a consultant in an
agency to help him learn how to do that
and right now he said I'm taking the
summer off so our growth this year might
still only be 2.5 or 3 million a year in
Revenue but I because I don't feel like
buying ads or staying on top of that so
I'm taking the summer off because we
just had a kid but it's super
fascinating to see a guy who basically
came from Zimbabwe didn't use the
internet until he was 12 13 and taught
himself how to do all this he's like one
of those really cool Tinkers and on that
blog post you can see pictures of him
like arriving from Africa and like
learning how to work the computer it's
super fascinating you'll see pictures of
him with his like iPhone and a laptop at
the gym filming people doing like the
curls so he can use his AI or whatever
to like get the 3D imaging really
fascinating company I think Jim streak
is awesome if this could get to 15 or 20
million a year in Revenue like he thinks
that would be a monster business for one
person yeah that's an amazing story wow
love that uh good for him that's that's
really really cool
um next category
business we most want to own so this is
um I think this is specifically a good
question because
for us a business we'd want to own would
be the lowest maintenance business
because neither of us want to really run
an extra business right now so it's like
which business would you want to own
because it is very much uh you know
autopilot so it's not design Joy it's
not
people are paying you and you're
providing a subscription it's not one of
those content or course businesses where
you constantly have to create new
content in order to stay relevant and
get more customers
um
I think we both have the same one let's
just do the same one that we we both are
really interested you you explain it go
for it no you go first all right
milled.com so most people don't know
mill.com it's
m-i-l-led.com and it's a really really
simple website it's just a compilation
of email marketing that different
companies do so
if you want to see like what are my
competitors sending for their fourth of
July sale
you just go to mill.com you search the
brand and you'll see okay here's what
Ridge wallet sent uh for their fourth of
July uh email it's the top one on the on
the Cyber site right now so it says you
know you just click and it shows you the
exact email that they sent so you can
see the design you can see the offer you
can see the copy and you could use that
to get inspiration for what you should
be doing for your email marketing and
this guy built the site uh I don't know
how long ago now but
um he's post on Hacker News a little bit
about it and it's one person it's a side
project he does a million dollars a year
on it he said I was I was doing email
marketing for a brand I noticed two
things one it took us several days to
create each email blast
um and two I had to subscribe to like
dozens of other competitor emails just
to do research for for them so my
hypothesis was I could create a site
that would just sign up for all the
brands uh you know email newsletters and
um and then make it easier for anybody
who's trying to do email marketing right
that's the uh that's that's the core
core pitch for it and he's just been
running it as a side project doesn't
take much maintenance doesn't you know
he could just do nothing on it for a
little while and it makes money through
ads yeah so so they use ads on the left
side here you can see like I have it
open and he's basically got like in a
like a link to the brand itself and then
he's got like a cyber security uh like
ad here popped up below it he's got like
a skincare ad yeah it's just display ads
so but here's another way how he makes
money so basically you're a marketer you
go to milled and you want to see like uh
it looks like some shoe brand they run
they ran this campaign and you want to
check out the email and you read it and
get inspired whatever you click that ad
and it takes you to the shoe company and
it's using an affiliate link if you buy
some of the shoes right this is a
horrible way to monetize this is a a
really amazing product under model under
monetized website for sure but good for
him for getting the traffic in the first
place but that's a horrible way to
monetize yeah yeah I agree uh but I
think the guy doesn't care he's just
like this is easy that's cool uh low
maintenance which is why I put it in my
one I'd want to own because it's low
maintenance and I think it still has a
lot of upside uh left
I'll do one for one I want to own so I
said anything that is like marketplacey
uh sort of like a Marketplace because
sometimes if you do it right those don't
they don't run themselves entirely but
the the community kind of handles the
business uh built with so built what was
started in 2015 or 16 probably built
with is like the most Niche ever
but there's it's a really big Niche so
you go to built with in order to see
which plugins a website is using if they
are using Wordpress and the reason why
that's important is you go to a website
that you like and you go oh I love this
feature they have let's go inside
without WordPress Shopify also that's
new it started with just WordPress I
think
um and so you're like just tell me like
the plugins and tell me the the
everything that they're using Shopify
and built with uh Shopify and WordPress
it has something like tens of millions
of people going there a month and does
at the time when I first found them I
think in 2020 I think they were doing 14
15 million in Revenue with just one
person so I think that would be a really
cool company to own
because I think it's super valuable once
you get all that traffic and those
people coming back to you all the time I
think it's a really valuable site do you
know anything about built with yeah uh
just what you told what you said there
I've been using it for a long time
basically if you see a website you want
to know what they use for whatever they
use
just go to build with it's pretty great
uh it's kind of like a data it's almost
like a data Index right it's like more
like a database than it is a Marketplace
in a way uh but I agree it's kind of
amazing
um all right let's keep going we got a
couple categories left we have a rookie
of the year so a new one a new a new one
that we found I think you might have
already covered yours uh in here but
dude it's boring I didn't want to say
the same thing twice but this guy Joe
mombre this Joseph mombre like I love
his story I think that this guy's gonna
be a big deal and I and I take a lot of
Pride to try to find people before
they're like really popular I think he's
read the blog post that I that I have
linked up there from the Hampton site
it's really good I think this guy's
Gonna Be A Winner so that's my Rookie of
the Year what's only finders only
finders is mine so this is one that I
don't know how old it is maybe a couple
years old now
um so only finders is a search engine
for only fans so if you want to find a
type of model on only fan so you you
know you're into you know blonde agents
or like you know whatever
good looking midgets whatever whatever
you're into you can search on only
finders and it'll give you a list of top
ranked profiles for that thing so as you
know I've been down the only fans Rabbit
Hole where I'm like I think there's a
lot of potential in the only fans uh
world of like businesses and this was
one of them that I found and
um only finders run by one guy he's
awesome he listens to the pod
he um and he crushes it so he crushes
the SEO game for for only fans if you
search for a bunch of different popular
searches
um and in fact actually what what he did
was smart which is he didn't want to
just rank for like the general uh
searches like best only fans or
something like that like he wants the
high intent ones so he wants the person
who's searching for like whatever I
don't know what people search for but
like redhead yeah redhead if you go to
his site if you go to his site you could
you click the button on the right hand
and it says like what the top searches
are so it's like Indian uh
he ranks really high for the categories
that people are that's like clearly
people's thing and it's like I don't
know what your thing is but I got if you
got a thing I got it for you and because
of that those are really really high
intense searches and then what he does
on the other side is he goes to only
fans models and agencies and he says hey
if you want more traffic I have tons of
people searching for your exact thing
pay me per click for every person I send
to you so he's basically recreated
Google it's a search engine where you
get paid per click to send a somebody
with intent to your to your to your site
and um he could do it he does a really
really good job and only fans does not
have a discover section on purpose they
decided they don't want to be in the
discovery business they want to only be
in the uh like the kind of the
underlying tools underneath these
Creator profiles and this is insane and
it's just been surfing the growth of
only fans which has grown like
exponentially like only fans a few years
ago was very small uh you know five
years whatever four five years ago it's
very small and then it got bigger bigger
it's like sort of like
I mean the curve looks looks unreal like
only fans is bigger than twitch it's
bigger than like some of these massive
websites uh now and it generates a lot
of money like they pay out billions to
creators uh on the platform and so if
you can be part of that ecosystem it's
valuable
that's interesting I have now met
multiple people and only fans that
you've never heard of
girls that are doing between one and two
million a month on their profile
because their body is the cogs so
there's
it's all profit basically they have like
you know usually they have like a
they'll they'll have like some of them
as you get bigger you have like a agency
that manages it
so what are they doing with this money
they're just they have huge income and
how long do you think can they do it for
five years three years yeah
and it's funny that someone kind of exit
they burn out and they'll just sell
their light name likeness and photo
library and be like you run it and just
give me a web show give me 50. it's like
Bruce Springsteen that's what he did the
same thing the boss uh this is insane I
I don't know much I I don't know much
about this uh this is absolutely
insane the engagement on these things
are wild if you have a holy fans
business reach out to me shot at
seanpuri.com I want to invest in only
fans businesses that are just cash flow
are they cool like when you met these
they're cool the problem is they're very
hard to sell and they're very easy to be
killed and so they need kind of like
strategy on like no I mean the girls oh
I don't know I don't know
you said you hung out with a couple of
them and I hang out with them I just
talked to them yeah they're nice people
I don't know
that's insane how did you get in touch
with them
it's the internet bro
what do you mean you know I've how many
times on here have I talked about only
fans and then people basically like oh
you're into that so that they email you
and then they they probably have a
million Indian guys like dming them uh I
mean that's insane this is inside
um I don't go through you know when you
see a big line at the front door you
don't you know you don't go wait in that
line you have to go find a side door and
the side door is generally you know some
some dude who listens to our podcast
that runs their business or as their
manager and that's kind of like the way
in all right let's that if we do or the
last category is the worst of the best I
have a different one but I would have to
say only fans would be up there but I
have another one the worst one is this
is these are all cool businesses but
which which one's our least favorite so
uh yours is gonna be only fans
no uh I mean it would be but I already
had something else Kevin Van Trump so
Kevin Van Trump I met this guy Sean
likes him a lot now uh I met him in 2000
and
2018. I was at a conference and Kevin
Van Trump is like six feet tall and he's
like really big he's like a very very
large overweight guy and he walks up to
me and he's got this super thick accent
he goes hey what's up man how you doing
like he just starts talking to me and
I'm like this guy's so confident and it
starts talking about all my newsletters
and the hustle and all this stuff and
he's got this thick accent he's wearing
a Ramones t-shirt and he's got like
Converse on he just looks like a like a
like a like a Walmart guy and then like
he dropped he drops like one or two
lines where for some reason we talked
about art but he was like oh yeah that
Picasso I got one of them some
like he said something like that I was
like what so I let it slide and then I
go how many subscribers are on your your
newsletter and he goes like Oh 60 000
and he goes hey how much you guys charge
for yours and I go oh it's free we make
money on ads you charge it goes yeah we
charge like 300 a month I forget exactly
what it was and I like do the math in my
head and I'm like wait that's 20 million
dollars a year he goes yeah it's
something like that I don't even know
and I started hanging out with him and
he basically this guy's name is Kevin
vandtrump he's got this newsletter where
he talks about agriculture and like how
it impacts commodity prices and it he's
brilliant and I get to know him a little
bit more and you're like oh no you just
have a Southern accent he like was a
Wall Street like Trader the guy's
brilliant he's amazing and he lives in
Kansas City and I've done a zoom call
with him and you see like he's got like
these custom built motorcycles in the
back of his like house and he's got like
all these picassos and the guy's
killing it but that same day when I hung
out with them I was like hey you know go
get dinner he's like yeah I can go get
dinner we we hang out at 8 30 he goes
hey man I gotta run I gotta write
tomorrow's newsletter and I was like
what he goes I do it every day I've done
it every day for 10 years I go what do
you mean every day he goes six days a
week I send a newsletter and it's 2 000
plus words it's really long he does it
every day and he was making all this
money I don't think I would trade lights
with him though just to have all that
money
I had the same answer I think he's
amazing you put me on to him I met him
and his son such awesome people so like
they're awesome super fun so awesome
just fun to be around smart
uh really nice just kind people don't
like you know no no pretense about them
um
and same thing he was hosting Farm con I
went because you had told me about him
and introduced me to him and when when I
go there he's we're at the conference
called Farm con he's got Farm con which
is like the biggest farming conference
get together so I go to Kansas and I and
was it awesome yeah it was amazing and
I'm there and we're talking it's like 11
at night it's like the whole event's
done everyone's at the bar
every single person is drinking a beer
and uh he's like I gotta get up gotta
get up to the bedroom gotta I gotta go
back to my room real quick right there
right tomorrow's Edition
and I was like wait you write it
yourself still and he's like yeah I
write it I've written it myself by hand
every night and he started this thing
more than 10 years ago like I think he
said like
it's almost like 20 years basically he's
been writing this thing 18 years or
something insane every day almost yeah
and it's long too it's not like just
some cookie cutter like here's Three
Links that are interesting it's like
no drone Powell came down said this but
and he said this said that you know
here's how this is going to affect corn
Futures and here's what I'm I'm betting
over here and then there's a bunch of
memes it's amazing
basically his market analysis for like
crap you know crop and commodities
and then it's a bunch of memes
underneath it and he's like nope never
do ads
um Isaac I just wanted to build as much
trust as I can in this community
and uh so I never advertise I I charge
for it and uh that's why we have Farm
con so everybody shows up is because you
know they I built a lot of trust over
the over the years and I learned more
about business from that guy in like one
hour than I did in my entire like
four-year education at Duke like he said
to me he said a bunch of things that I
loved I put this in my my newsletter I
did a feature on him that I wrote a
bunch of the lessons but one of them
that he said was
he goes yeah the content's cool but he's
like being he goes being an investor is
the best job in the world you kidding me
uh he's like and he just said it so
matter of fact that he's like there is
no better job in the world than being an
investor
it is it is the best and you sort of
think about that you're like all right
well that sounds you know whatever I
guess kind of obvious
and it's like okay if that's true then
how do you get into that job like if if
that is true for you
um how do you architect your life to get
there because he's basically just like
look this newsletter is great yeah
question makes a lot of money
but I wish I was just an investor uh it
would have been a better better better
choice blah blah they talked about
investing because he I think he was on
Wall Street before he started doing what
he was doing yeah and he goes um he goes
you know one thing I only he goes I was
early into Bitcoin I was early into
Facebook I was like really and he's like
yeah he's like I wasn't as early as I
could have been he's like but there's
always uh he's like I got into Bitcoin
like in 20 he's like we started hearing
about it at Farm con like in 2013 2014 I
didn't buy it till 2015 2016. I should
have been in it right when I first heard
it he's like same thing with Facebook he
goes one one lesson I learned in
investing he goes um he goes two two
lessons for you in investing number one
the best trades are gonna be ones where
bones where you buy them you put them in
the drawer you never think about them
again he's like he's like that was the
best thing I did about Bitcoin I bought
Bitcoin I put it in the drawer never
thought about it again heard all the
news didn't care it's in the drawer and
I was like damn in the drawer that's a
cool concept of like what investments
can you just have the conviction and you
put in the drawer you say I'm not gonna
react to the Daily News cycle about this
investment I'm gonna let the 10 years
play out on this investment because it
was a let's see what happens on the
long-term type of BET
um second thing he said was he goes uh
you always get a second chance to get on
the train with the best investments
there's always a second chance on the
train he's like with Bitcoin you know
you think you missed it and then the
price will come down that's your chance
to get back on the train and most people
by that time you know they spend the
whole way up wishing they had got on the
train train comes back around and they
get scared they don't get back on yeah
same thing happened with Facebook
Facebook you know we had our chances uh
when it was Private then it goes public
it goes up up crashed back down to 19 I
got back on the track that train came
around I got right back on and he's like
yo that will happen for the best
investments and I sort of look for this
now of like uh how do you override the
psychology that most people have which
is when it's going up you wish you had
gotten in earlier then when it crashes
down you're too afraid to buy in because
you feel like oh is it over did it
pop is it did I miss it
um was I wrong and it's like well then
you lose lose you know you want to buy
on the way up and you don't want to buy
on the way down that's that's a recipe
for being poor right like you know buy
High don't buy low right that's not
gonna work and so uh those two little
lessons were ones that stuck out for me
but this guy's business is amazing he's
an amazing guy and the reason he's
amazing among other things is he breaks
all the stereotypes he you you'll think
that he's just this like hickey guy just
like people used to think about me uh
and like I grew up around people just
like him turns out he's like brilliant
he'll he'll like you're like you're
gonna talk to me about Facebook and he
knows way more about it than you do
he'll probably knows all about Bitcoin I
mean the guy's brilliant and uh I love
hanging out with him and his friends
because you it teaches you like I'm a
idiot for judging people a
certain way these guys are all badass
dude and they're fun as I did a
call the other day with another guy so
uh another guy from Farm con same same
sort of guy he's this uh white guy maybe
I don't know
it is 50s ish something like that was he
Super Rich because so many of those guys
are super rich and I think this guy I
don't know how racist guy private jet
rich I don't know how rich this guy is
but the guy who introduced me to him was
just like yeah this guy's worth you know
300 500 million dollars personally and I
was like Wow uh okay that's crazy
because I was like I was like do his
deals like he's always talking about
these deals like does he actually make
money on these like is he had it track
record of success he's like yeah he has
um so this guy this guy's got phrases
for days so I I have this doc that I
keep on my phone I call phrases except
somebody says something that's just like
funny or worded well it just sticks out
to me it's a Punchy phrase I write it
down at Farm con I filled out my phrases
thing like because there were so many so
this one guy
um I don't want to say his name put him
on blast but he uh he was at a dinner
with uh says Kevin vantrum and this guy
was at the dinner it was like a private
dinner at the at Farm con and uh he
stands up and he goes everyone on the
table is doing introductions and sit
there I'm like you know how I am Sean
and yeah I work in Tech and uh
just kill me I guess I'm boring
like you know like that's basically like
how I felt during the introduction this
guy stands up he goes yeah my name's so
and so he goes um you know
uh
he goes
exactly where he said he goes he goes uh
I don't know who won the World Series
I can't tell you how to get a six-pack
abs hell I don't even know where the
remote is in my house but I know one
thing I know how to structure deals and
today I'm gonna tell you guys about a
deal that I'm doing and you're like gave
this intro and I was like what did he
Crush I was like what an incredible way
to introduce yourself I don't know where
the remote is but I know one thing I
know deals and I was like that is
incredible then he's uh he's talking
about how old he is he goes he cut me in
half there's gonna be a lot of rings
that's the best nice and then he goes
and then I did a call with him the other
day and uh I get on the zoom call and I
had just finished my workout and my
trainer was like insisting because I was
like dude I gotta run I gotta be on this
call he's like all right just take your
call but let's do your like kind of like
we try to do like this like myofascial
like kind of like you're rolling like a
like a foam roller type of thing like
you're you're kind of like foam rolling
out at the end so we were doing it and
he's like just do it while you're on the
call foam rolled with this guy so I get
on the call I turn on the video and I'm
like yeah I'm gonna show them what's
going on so I'm like sorry if uh sorry
this looks weird I'm doing like some
stretching
yes
the big dude he goes okay cool if uh if
it looks like I'm stretching call 9-1-1
because I'm having a stroke
dude why would you take a call like that
incredible win like to have that line
immediately ready when I say you know
that I'm stretching if sorry if it looks
weird I'm trying to I was like wow that
was literally so funny to me I
was blown away I was like I don't care
what else happens on this call that that
was so impressive so good
what state did he live in uh he's in
Tennessee I think
what the hell is a deal struck I don't
even know what that means like he like
he does he's like private Equity so he
buys companies
um but he's like I just know how to find
a great deal how to put the financing
together and how to structure it so that
like I get the maximum value out of
these deals it's kind of like what he
does
um and like you know I'm like so I was
like I was like you know what um
uh I was like have you done any deals
like that I would have heard of
and he's like you know Disneyland I was
like yeah he's like a lot of Windows in
Disneyland we do all the windows in
Disneyland so
oh my God they bought a window company
got him a Disney contract we do all the
windows at Disney
do what with the windows like clean them
this guy's incredible
what's yours for uh world uh worst of
the best
um I had both design joy and the Kevin
Trump just because of the time thing so
I love that Kevin vantrope has built
like this this amazing power niche in
the farming industry but I uh I would
not want to be the guy who has to write
the newsletter every night because the
pressure is it's got to go out tomorrow
morning I felt that during milk Road for
a month and I was like nope not doing it
this way yeah although I think if I was
him I would just find a way to hire
somebody to do that like I can't believe
he hasn't done that yet
um does Ben Thompson still do I haven't
read this oh yeah so Ben Thompson is my
version of that so he does strategory
and every day he writes a newsletter
about
basically the same four things
and I don't even know how he does that
like he talks about Facebook Google
Amazon Apple Netflix and like what's
going like the kind of the business and
strategy of what they're doing they're
so long these are so long he does this
daily long form his audience is like has
the highest bar his audience is like the
smartest people in the tech industry uh
like you know VCS and all that that's
who reads him every morning so he's got
to come with like original content
that's super smart about the same topics
he's been doing this for like a decade
and he makes three million dollars a
year roughly doing this office paid and
he only charges 120 a year yeah I think
he upped his price I don't know what it
is now but he like did raise his prices
at some point 120 um it's 12 I think it
was 100 and now it's 120.
a month uh for this thing you know but
but he's you know I think Ben's awesome
uh so I don't beat it as a knock for him
I'm saying I would hate the pressure of
the daily super insightful thing that I
have to write every every morning
original content about like the same
kind of like 10 companies is uh I don't
I literally don't even know how he does
it if somebody told me they're gonna do
that I'd be like what are you saying
this makes no sense and uh he does it
every day sitting in Taiwan this is the
worst this is the worst it is it is
amazing
um but um yeah I would never want to do
this um so what do we think that I
wonder what I want to know the listener
if they think that these one
all in depth on one topic if they dig
this if they dig the award category
style or the award style what do you
think yeah this is an experiment for us
of like doing a few focused episodes
themed episodes so today's theme was
these one or two person businesses that
crush it
um do you like this or do you like the
freestyle freestyle's a lot easier this
one takes a lot of work but if people
love this you got to go in the YouTube
comments and show us if we should do
more of these or no uh we're cool either
way but this is an experiment so let us
know in the YouTube comments dude I
stressed out for so long doing this
these These are these are emotional for
me can I give some takeaways because I
don't think we did that uh I think we
should do some takeaways all right so
here's my my quick takeaways the most
common Industries you see these one to
two person businesses that Crush are uh
just like thought leader on it on social
media so just putting out free content
on social media e-commerce we didn't do
any Ecom ones in this but like there's a
bunch of e-commerce that could do like
you know a million dollars a year in
profit that are run with one or two
people and then you can do agencies for
everything else
um games so we talked about stardew
Valley Minecraft there's a bunch of
games that are built like this
um apps and plugins so plug-ins on top
of things like a figma plug-in a Google
Sheets plugin a Gmail plug-in that sort
of thing and then data aggregators like
built with which are basically compiling
data like mill.com compiling bunch of
things that are of the same thing so
it's you go search and you find what you
want uh because they've aggregated
everything only finder same thing it's a
data aggregator
um strategy so here's a couple strategy
points you need to be either amazing 100
awesome at distribution meaning you're
the influencer you're the content
creator or you need to be 100 awesome on
product you're the guy coding the game
and and you'll you'll hire a publisher
to do the publishing and so I think that
if I was going to do this if I was gonna
try to make this happen I would say
where can I be either an incredible at
distribution or incredible that product
and I want to just like put all of my
emphasis on that
um in order to make this happen
the next one you need attributes so a
lot of these we made sound simple
but you gotta have some attributes some
skill copywriting design uh you know the
ability like investment judgment market
analysis like you got to be expert on
one of these things if you're gonna make
this happen and so you know you got to
get to that expert master master of your
craft level if you're gonna do this uh
the last one it's all about leverage so
the way you can get a one or two person
company to get to Millions tens of
millions or even some of the examples we
gave were hundreds of millions of
dollars
um was leveraged so you need to be using
code
uh build it once and then it runs as
software you need to use uh media like
podcasts or newsletters or whatever or
you need to use Capital because you're
not going to use labor right like most
companies use labor that's why they have
hundreds of people working for them but
if you're going to not have hundreds of
people working you got to use these
other forms of Leverage code
Capital some money or media are your
tools of choice you got to figure out
which of those three can I use and
that's how I'm going to do it and the
beauty of it is because of the internet
if you're the best at X you now get to
sell to the whole world so like we
didn't give an example Miss Excel so
miss Excel is this girl who goes on Tick
Tock and she in a high energy way dances
and tells it teaches you how to use
Excel like Microsoft Excel better
and she's the best in the world at
teaching Excel it turns out the best of
the world of teaching Excel is you know
how to do the pop you know the useful
stuff and you can dance turns out that's
what the best teacher of excel look like
and she now gets to teach the entire
world Excel like the best of anything
gets to is to provide that product
service or education to everybody that's
the beauty of of the internet and so you
need to figure out how to become the
best of X because and then just make it
available to everybody
and the last thing I I was going to say
was it's lonely like the best
times that I have in work is when I'm
whether it's in the trenches and like
it's a shitty day or it's a great day is
celebrating with co-workers these jobs
are lonely I'm actually surprised when I
hear about this about like how they are
able to push like I push myself because
oh I have Milds to feed or I want to be
held accountable by these other people
and make them proud it's really hard to
push yourself this hard and to think big
when you're by yourself and it's just
hard to do this every day alone so
hopefully you have like a good spouse or
a significant other or something because
it's just challenging I I mean when I
started this I was like oh I want to be
a solo solopreneur
I wanted to be a solopreneur or they
call it a solo capitalist I raised a
fund and it's like I want to be a solar
capitalist
and I was like oh this isn't fun at all
to do this by yourself yeah and not only
is it not that good to do things by
yourself because you know a little bit
of help can go a long way a
complimentary person who's good at the
things you're not good at is really
really useful
but on top of that it ain't no fun and
like most of life is the journey not the
destination and you don't want to have
the shitty Journey for this awesome
destination and so very quickly I was
like yeah this is a duopreneur this is
being bad doing this or in the fun it's
me and rameen doing this and I basically
immediately was like I'm gonna do this
even my econ business I gave a chunk of
it to a guy who was smarter than me and
had done this before and would give me
some money and I was like why just
because like I don't want to be
reporting into myself and only like have
myself as a thought partner to be
sparring with on ideas about this I want
to have somebody awesome just to do some
you know idea jousting on this and so uh
I think doing it by yourself is honestly
a terrible idea you should definitely
try to get one other person to do this I
think two people is the is the sweet
spot where you get sort of the the most
autonomy and the least like management
headaches and you have uh you still get
the most done and have a lot of fun
along the way
all right that's the Pod whether you're
listening on iTunes or Spotify or
whatever go to uh search my first
million on YouTube and go to the
comments on this video and actually let
us know we'll read them and see if we
should keep doing these that's it
[Music]